welcome to this video playing out core
layer Cornwall and call a corner maybe
upgrade with those surnames okay check
yeah the names oh Zima sh and canon
again but they're free how it's like the
position so it's a it's it's just just
entertaining to play if he goes tonight
d 6 can i play 585 and i take c for
Queenie too well maybe could be a an
interesting way to play yeah I'll kill
I'll close it up try to prove that that
the night only eight is not well placed
okay yeah here there are interesting
possibilities
I'm having to crazier I haven't crazy
idea Sam hg4 maybe maybe this is
possible this is this type of type of
quick attack yeah I think this is what
you should do get that i get rid of them
the bishop here okay so castling yeah g4
is not really one maybe if i have
castles queen a three and then g4s is
dangerous yeah also here g4s again
dangerous okay let's do that the same in
this opening you really should should
strike if you see some aggressive
continuation it's a very often just the
way to go okay so why should I should
probably take here then see if I have
tried to open up the e5 school area
maybe the first king h1 runs right into
the long diagonal I'm not sure about
that ah I notice this positions are
really really hard to play
yeah but okay you cannot really play 94
right running right into into a pin
check would be surprised if this is
possible even King g3 is probably good
against that maybe instead of King f2 I
could have played h3 h3 King edge tool
but okay okay taking f5 is probably not
good young
now what saved e5 if intending 90 form
and I with this Knight g4 check
you talk about talk about a difficult
position maybe you should just play
rookie adium
check
yeah where do I do now kicking g3 SF is
funky right into rock g8 King you one
looks all so weird nothin but maybe I
need to do that
yeah I really don't don't know why I
mean have 94 taking f5 are very unclear
we now exchange you're only 16 d 294 hmm
maybe that's not so bad but check when I
it's got night f to wear night f2 can be
can be a problem 94 I think night f2 is
maybe maybe good time warning
yeah I need nice gotten i def to wear
yeah I need need someplace for the
kingdom check the five or so is falling
anyway I guess
hmm very tough to play with rookie seven
also and that could be could be could be
good for words rook air-five is a cameo
key aide made coming Brooke age seven
made no oh
this looks looks winning I mean that the
bishop is also just hanging on b7 still
thread chat look rupee eight rookies
sambuca Jade made they don't see black
resign there's no defense to that there
was a sudden end to this game pretty
surprising yeah it was it was very
complicated all this and i think around
here i am I should I should have
something I with a computer actually
likes king of two I didn't like it after
I played it ok i took here maybe i
should i should first of course i should
first do this because taking here
allowed allowed Knight f6 yakking
afterwards better i had played this I
had an idea my idea was to play a play
this move yeah to make sure that I get a
knight to e5 but then I realized after
the trade that this is coming as well so
I don't really have anything great here
so I switched back to this and I could
have played King f2 without taking on d6
and then the night would have been
passive check yeah and here probably the
the game is jess is turning into blacks
favor you know this the computer thinks
is a mistake just Ruby aid check yeah no
II five is strong yeah you have
threatening you for yeah that's indeed
strong after that germ it seems to be
check that white is ok again
check this is given us equal by the
computer with Bishop c8 and this is f5
and now Bishop a6 must be played after
this rookie seven white is white is
winning a remarkable yeah I was also
surprised that all of a sudden I'm
winning but he has no defense the
relatively best seems to be rook g2
after which i can take check and take
him ie the wind is still not trivial at
least in a blitz can I think white is
some in the computer assessing it is
winning is may be right but mm-hmm now
because FFF strong active pieces here
the knight on d4 is well-placed but
still my pawn structure is not great
yeah interesting not quite sure how easy
it is to win this in a blitz game but
does he should have tried for sure okay
thanks for watching